hi there Steve Kaufman here yeah I
thought I would talk today about what
makes an effective language teacher and
the reason I want to talk about it is
because I again was on that list server
of language teachers and one of the
people asked or made the comment that so
many English teachers don't have a real
good grasp of grammar and isn't this a
pity and they were all talking about how
great grammar was and that you know you
have ESL teachers who who don't really
aren't deep into their grammar and I
commented they're like why does that
matter
I'm sure the average English teacher
speaks English at least as well as the
average native speaker and if the
learner is able to speak as well as the
average native speaker I think the
learner is probably gonna be quite happy
so why does it matter and then I thought
to myself when I have been studying
languages if I had a choice between
speaking to someone who is a average
person engineer housewife secretary
whatever but who is pleasant and
interesting versus someone who has four
degrees in linguistics who would I
rather have as a teacher I know I don't
want the linguistics teacher I don't
want someone who's gonna make a point of
teaching me a bunch of rules so yeah you
don't want someone who speaks their own
language poorly but a native speaker who
speaks their own language quite well but
doesn't know any grammar rules to me
makes an excellent language teacher I
think a language teacher is a bit of an
art it's a is a performer is a performer
it's like if you were running a if you
were picking people to play on your team
in a sport whatever that sport might be
you don't want someone who has is you
know has read the countless books on how
to play soccer you want someone who's
just a good soccer player and I think
that the
be an effective teacher the most
important thing is how well you're able
to motivate other people to learn it's
your personality first of all in a class
and I can I admit that running a classes
must be a very difficult thing to do
because you've got 20 individuals with
varying degrees of interest in the
subject and somehow you've got to make
you've got to perform for 50 minutes or
however long it is and you've got to try
to motivate those people to get
interested in what they're doing so I
also think that so therefore that that
whatever they they you know I have a
discussion today with someone in the
Canadian government trying to interest
them in link of course that was more or
less of a futile effort because they
have this is for immigrant learning they
have their own system it's called the
Canadian language benchmarks and and if
you aren't somehow meshed with that
system then they have no interest in you
because they feel it in fact I was told
it's very important for both the
teachers and the learners to have these
common frames of a common frame of
reference and common methodology and
terminology and so forth and I thought
that myself like none of that matters at
all you know a creative teacher will
respond to a situation whether it be
with an individual or with a group of
people in a class we'll find a way to
keep them interested find things for
them to do that that they will find
interesting and to try to straitjacket
everybody into a certain fixed
methodology which is typically what they
teach or maybe they don't but that was
certainly what the this Canadian
benchmarks seemed to imply and and and
certainly it's the flavor that I get
from this from this listserv that I'm on
this somehow all the things that the
language teachers or some of them at
least feel is an important part of their
sort of credibility and credentials in
other words having taken certain courses
knowing the grammar inside out and
backwards and forwards many of these
things are probably not so important in
terms of the success of the learner far
more important to me is the personality
the resourcefulness of the teacher the
ability to empathize to motivate to turn
on so it seems to me that it's it's kind
of strange that unlike say being a
doctor you don't want to be operated on
by someone who doesn't have the
credentials and you wouldn't want
someone trying to fix your car who
doesn't have the credentials because
there are very specific scientific bits
of knowledge that you must have you must
know how an engine works but language
teaching is not like that language
teaching is not like surgery or fixing
your car or building a bridge language
teaching is about turning on someone's
emotions interests enthusiasm dealing
with their sense of frustration their
lack of confidence
somehow inspiring them to put the effort
in to listen to learn to imitate to
connect with another language and those
skills the skills required to achieve
that are more the skills of a performer
than they are the skills of a technician